Alice you won your game yesterday and
today you had to defend you played the
Petrov but the Petrov is such a
difficult opening to master and you
haven't played it before is that correct
um I think I've had a few games before
but not as my main opening in the Petrov
um so this game I think I I actually
didn't really like the opening position
I got
um I like the Early Middle game position
um but then later I felt like I played
too passively did you feel like she was
building up some pressure in the middle
game yeah I felt like she played like
really well but it was just hard for her
to play um I think she was probably
winning but she was in time pressure at
what point did you feel like she was
piling on the pressure uh I think after
she was uh like we traded off into like
the
um
like the two Rooks and Bishop versus uh
all the way there okay okay yes um but
earlier I think
um like somewhere around here yeah
around here I felt like
um I was oh actually I'm supposed to
explain
I guess that makes sense I probably
straw
um maybe and then Queen to E4 this is a
difficult move to see yeah that's like
30 minutes if you take take your a pawn
just runs yeah I definitely didn't see
that if I seen it then I also probably
have played it because I at least have a
draw there with Queen F4 exactly yeah
and you play The Rook to f8 wouldn't you
feel like she maybe has something
to disturb you I felt like
maybe around when she was able to like
get the Deep one a bit more forward yes
I feel like it was definitely hard I
wasn't sure I didn't see it in exact one
for her
um ever but of course I was like also on
time pressure so
um I think after she was able to like
get this Roxy sex movement I felt like
my position was kind of uncomfortable
because if I do kin G7 then there's work
C7 and I didn't really like that
um so after like Queen E3 uh
F6 yeah kimchi seven and it doesn't seem
like she had anything at any point yeah
I thought it was this maybe she has like
um after we traded I actually wasn't
sure because I felt like I'm either like
completely winning or completely losing
and you were winning yeah with King G7
yeah I felt like maybe she could like uh
try to do like 57 C5 C6 or Bishop uh B7
C5 C6 but I didn't actually see any
place where it ever worked because I
have the skinny five move
um but yeah I was definitely like uh not
an easy game for me to play I think
um practically speaking it could have
gone wrong at like any moment if
um and I got a bit lucky like here I
have a skinny five move but yeah after
Bishop FC was happy with his like
working exception trading into the
component game Alice congratulations a
huge victory for you tomorrow you still
have a big match against Nazi pakiza to
prepare for we'll let you go get some
rest thank you our congratulations to
you Alice as we get ready for our